this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 20. Echo Charles and I sitting
here getting ready to talk about some
things we're kind of talking about
things rolling into this here's the
topic
that I'm gonna bring up because it's
something that we need to think about so
we all talk about
I talk about got to be humble right sure
got to be humble
humble we can get humbled which can be a
positive thing oh you know I was humbled
in this game because I thought I was
pretty good but then I got smoked
so I got humbled now I need I know I
need to go back and practice more but
there could be a line that gets crossed
from time to time from humbled to
humiliated
let me tell you why I'm bringing this up
a guy named Dean list Dean Lister
so we were training the other day
now listen for since the beginning of
time of Dean listener and I training for
20
5 or 26 or 27 years together
if I have a really good day
and he has a really bad day
it's a pretty good scrap right you see
what I'm saying if I have a really good
day I'm on I'm fresh I'm warm I'm
feeling good if I have a really good day
and and on top of that he has a really
bad day where he's tired worn out
doesn't want to train you know whatever
mentally worn down if that's the
situation we might have a good match
right
any other situation he's gonna he's
gonna kind of crush me
if I'm having a bad day
and he's having a good day
it can be a real problem yeah so the
other day he was not only this might
sound strange he was not only having a
good day he was like in a playful yet
punitive mode where because you know
like I will I'll get my digs on Dean
Lister right whether they're verbal you
know or it's on the mat like hey when
when I have the upper hand I'm going to
capitalize on that yeah when he has the
upper hand
he's going to capitalize but like I said
if he has the upper hand it's a much
it's much more up yeah
so he was just ragdolling me ragdolling
me
uh he was holding me by my bet we were
in ghee he was holding me by my like
belt and lapel
my my lapel was somehow like wrapped
around my leg and and he was dragging me
around the mat
um
just laughing at me yeah that's bad so
now you might think okay Jocko you've
been
I
look I've been training Jiu Jitsu for a
long time
okay
physically I work out a lot right so I'm
not in bad condition right in fact I
would venture so far as to say if if
Dean and I were in like a fitness
competition right I would probably beat
him in quite a few things there's a
couple things that he is mutantly strong
at but broadly speaking now you would
never feel that on the map if you rolled
with him and you rolled me on the mat
you'd be like Jocko's weak this guy is
can can must be able to clean and jerk
nine thousand pounds yeah that's what he
feels like on the map for sure
so it's not like I'm
exponentially weaker than him it's not
like I got I wasn't even gassed that's a
really scary thing I wouldn't even
gassed I was just I was helpless like a
child
like a child
and I'm a 230 pound man that's been
training Jiu-Jitsu for a really long
time so
and you know here's the thing I mean I
know the deal
like I'm having fun like I'm laughing
I'm like yeah this sucks we're with Wes
Wes is just like yeah this is just this
is unfortunate to watch it's just a
bummer like hey I'm sorry that this is
happening that's the way it is so
here's the deal
the training ends you know we then he
showed me a couple things you know he's
like oh here's something here's
something you know we we work through
some moves and he's an incredible
instructor
um but then I had to go home
and the drive home the drive home which
isn't a far drive it takes me you know
10 minutes yeah it seemed like 10 hours
bro that's real that part of it seemed
like 10 hours and I was questioning what
is wrong with me what was wrong with me
how did this even happen yeah am I even
a person
am I have I wasted my whole life
doing something for no reason and I'm a
Loser yeah
so
you know I took that long 10-hour drive
home in my mind
and what are you gonna do so I figure
it's a good topic to talk about because
it happens in all aspects of life right
you show up to do a presentation at work
and you bomb it you go up and talk to a
a female and you know looks at you like
whatever whatever these series of
rejections are that are going to happen
these these not just humbling moments
but it's one step further like it's one
thing you you know you're young and you
go up to a girl to talk to her and she
says hey you know I have a boyfriend but
nice to meet you right okay that's cool
yeah yeah and maybe it's a little bit
stronger than that maybe it's like Hey
listen I'm not really looking for you
know a dude right now but later yeah but
it could just be like why do you think
you are on a level where you would be
talking to me right it could be
something crazy right yeah
could be you know same thing at work
like you could look you mess up and you
know the boss says hey hey man you need
to tighten it up and you're like yeah
sorry I need to I need to prepare way
more
or it could be like hey man I don't know
if I'm Gonna Let You present in front of
clients again
that was ridiculous kind of ever so
what are we gonna do
um I I just have to say like step one
you gotta get back on the horse right
you heard that expression before right
if you fall off the horse you got dinged
up your ego's dinged up
I was actually looking forward to my
next training session because I'm I'm
like there's no way it's going that bad
there's no way I could train with anyone
in the entire world then it's going to
go that bad yeah it was bad
so you gotta you gotta put yourself into
the mode of like okay I had a bad day I
had it do you remember
chandau you remember him Alex shandow
was his nickname he's a jiu jitsu guy
and he was with us at Fabio Santos and
um
he would say
you have days and days that was what he
would say basically he was trying to say
you have good days and bad days but he
just said you had days and days which is
legit right because those kind of days
could be anything so it's the truth
though you have days and days yeah
so sometimes you have days and days the
good day is cool we're all stoked we
don't need to worry about them all good
if you have one of the other days then
you got to put that you got to say okay
we reached a new low yep now it's time
to start climbing up again and it's okay
you learned something and I did I
learned it I did learn a couple things
you know I gave me a couple grip things
to talk to me about my hip displacement
you know all these code words
so you learn but
I just want to let everybody know
that there's days and days and there's
sometimes you get humbled and sometimes
you get straight up humiliated
and it's okay
get back on the horse see what you can
learn
and the worst thing you could do
the worst thing you could do on that
drive home is say this isn't for me you
know what I mean yes and that that has
to happen to people where they just say
you know what I'm done
this isn't worth it this isn't whatever
you're doing you know you try to win a
race you don't win it you try you know
what I mean you get to a point where you
say
you know this just isn't for me that's
what you got to be careful of
pick up the
gotta get your gear back on
you
that drive home and you know obviously
you know you say you got humiliated
obviously not a common thing
um
I would say once a quarter maybe twice a
quarter sure right so like once or twice
every three months I'm having a bad day
Dean's having an awesome day and he's in
a
in a comical mood right because he
thinks it's funny yeah and he's he wants
to laugh yeah which is also
additional humiliation yeah and what I
mean not to go too deep on the Dynamics
is you have a so it's going to depend on
your personality too so Dean has that
personality where he'll eat that per
that that laughing part that joking part
of it
um he he is pretty much from the
beginning always had that attitude with
me and he'll I think because I dig it I
I feel like I have that same thing where
if someone's talking to me like joking
about it like telling me how all that
that that attempt sucked or something
and insane it it makes it more fun yeah
like just a funner thing yeah true
otherwise in this I'm putting this
extreme just for the example but
otherwise it feels kind of like oh like
this means so much if I beat you or if
you beat me or whatever this means so
much there's a lot of the line and I
don't really like that feeling and you
did when I'm training with my friends
anyway uh it's not you know what do I do
uh you do both but you don't do it while
you roll you do it between the rolls
you'll like give looks and be like oh
how did that feel or something like that
so I dig it and I like it you know what
I try and do I try not to get the
emotions into it right yeah I'm trying
not to like uh say something and be I'm
trying not to be snarky about the whole
scenario you know what I mean yeah
except for with one person Dean Lister
yeah like if he's having a bad day and
I'm having a good day I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna talk some [ __ ] yeah but
so you talk [ __ ] it's more enjoyable
though right yeah that's just fun yeah
so it's gonna depend on your personality
like I can't wait till I have a good day
and he has a bad day in the near future
yeah
so I hope
um
so either way either way when you and
you know what though like it's crazy how
like when you're not rolling or when it
doesn't happen to you your brain is all
clear like oh yeah you have good days
and bad days you got days and days right
no like that's actually a good one yeah
I'm gonna incorporate it now but it's
easy to be like yeah you have good days
and bad days or when someone else goes
through it hey bro don't worry about it
you know like you you know you you know
you've been training this for a long
time you got to know you got good days
and bad days you know but when it the
day it happens to you and the weird
thing it's weird on the drive home right
you feel it and it's almost like no bro
I don't even know if I even can do Jiu
Jitsu anymore like I know all the moves
it like I think I do but like man and
that's every single time man and I think
even every level I think white belt is
like all the time and you're like man I
suck at this
when you're you know you make yourself
or you make your way up the ranking or
whatever and that happens it's like it's
almost more painful because you're like
oh yeah I have a black belt you know
I've never heard of a black belt getting
treated the way I just got treated I
never even heard of it yeah I got to
like you sometimes like when you're in
your mood or whatever like you'll get me
with that Guillotine like
eight times in one round that's a lot
that's a lot that's more than one a
minute yeah that's a lot and I'll have
that feeling like like am I in this
feeling like I have a black belt from
Jocko himself and I literally have no
physical capability or mental capability
to stop him from joking me out eight
times you know what I just realized no I
said I don't like to be snarky you know
what I realized I'm actually doing is
I'm letting that just run around in your
own head without saying anything
on the Savage I'm like bro I'm like yeah
and so it's real though it's real but
you're right though at the end of the
day it's like you know and this is me
being totally detached because I
probably feel that way worse than you
when I drive home
um where like I know like you know how
good I am or am not you know so I can't
be like trying to brag to you how good I
am or trying to you know because you
know bro we've been freaking training
together literally for
since I started since I was a white belt
yeah so you know nothing I can say or do
is gonna give you the impression now
that I'm all of a sudden freaking
awesome and you know so it's like you
kind of gotta keep that in in mind you
know so it kind of puts everything into
perspective and yeah man you freaking
that those bad days aren't gonna
freaking hurt and it's it kind of makes
me feel good that you had that day yeah
recently I'm good because you deserve it
sometimes you know what else yeah thank
you uh I'm so I've had so many of those
days that I already kind of know about
them right I am like I'm making I'm sort
of making a bigger deal out of it to
explain because I know that people the
first time that happens to you in any
environment you might think like this
this is just me I'm the only person
that's ever getting been humiliated like
this yeah I've been humiliated enough
times that it's like oh you know what
yeah cool it's nice it's not a big shock
to my sister my drive home nowadays
isn't it's 10 minutes it doesn't seem
like 10 hours it seems like 20 minutes
you know know there's some extra time
there running around there's some ideas
bouncing around in the head yeah some
excuses are coming in right there's some
excuses rolling in you know well you
know Dean's been doing this and well you
know he's Bob yeah you know I have a you
know life to work yeah he just gets to
do yeah all those things oh yeah no
they're all lies they're all lies it's
all part of the game right there though
but the um and and that does apply to
everything kind of like how you were
saying in the beginning kind of applies
to everything this is when it'll it can
shock you even if your quote unquote
used to it is when you're on a run on a
streak of just killing it whether it be
Jiu Jitsu or at work is a good one where
like and then you mess up or I don't
know something happens or whatever or in
Jiu-Jitsu yeah you have a straight up
bad day and you kind of get shocked and
you're like oh my gosh it was all a lie
you know me telling myself whatever that
happened to me when I was about with
Greg McIntyre I was I was competing a
lot I was breathing and on the run on
the on a run big time
and Greg Tran humiliated you great and
he even told me later that he had heard
about it you know and was like oh man
that's good you know like maybe you know
he could be a good training partner but
he was gonna kind of bring it next time
we trained oh yes I'm gonna break it off
and break them off yeah break him off
yeah bro he broke me off so hard like
real like methodically too you know how
when someone's there to break you off
you kind of know you can feel it like oh
okay this guy I see it I get it like
you're gonna bring it to show me your
last in or just show you know let me
break gonna break me off I get it but
you can feel it I didn't even feel it I
just felt that bro this guy is kind of
just stoppable just no there is no
Theory that's a thing it was almost like
he just methodically dismantled me and
then sort of just walked away and he was
like yeah good training you were like
done shocked shocked the Run has come to
it has come to an end but when that
happens get back on the horse no Factor
all right let's get some q a what do we
got all right
how would you handle someone that gets
mad and walks away or gets mad and will
not respond to you when you're trying to
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground